all right our first story we got this
from the daily caller nbc deletes tweet
comparing immigrants to trash yes
i just you know i didn't expect it to go
this far so quickly so fast ron de santa
sent 50 illegal immigrants to martha's
vineyard and it was like a political
nuclear bomb take a look at this
nbc tweeted florida governor desantis
sending asylum seekers to martha's
vineyard is like quote me taking my
trash out and just driving to different
areas where i live and just throwing my
trash there a founding member of a
foundation which helps refugees says wow
that is a not only indicative of nbc
news is what they're willing to publish
because they didn't need to choose that
quote but also these ngos these these
non-profits that claim to help these
people you see what they really think
about them it reminds me of when uh that
osborne woman was on the view or
whatever yeah
you deport these people who's gonna
clean your toilet and they were like you
remember that that's what she said right